[Music]
this morning on the dish a major force
in Boston's culinary scene chef Lydia
Shire was born and raised in the suburb
of Brookline where her artist father
loved to cook and she'd help out in the
kitchen she went on to cooking school
but may have learned the most from some
amazing mentors including Julia Child
and Wolfgang Puck and she returned the
favor herself mentoring a new generation
of top boston cooking talent many of
whom worked in the 6 Boston restaurants
she opened over the years and that list
includes scumbo now marking its 10th
anniversary we're shires son Alex is a
sous chef chef Lidia Shire good morning
welcome to the dish thank you
what a great looking table tell us all
about it well my husband is from
Columbia South America and does not like
Turkey every year I have to of course I
cook the turkey but then I also make a
big hunk of pork for him usually a pork
belly or a roast shoulder or something
like that so we have a little shoulder
happening here so this is a taste of
your typical Thanksgiving dinner yes
without the turkey but the other parts
are here you know we have a beautiful
acorn squash with more bacon more pork
lots of butter and brown sugar it's
delicious to make we have a little pear
salad I think is nice some biscuits with
rum butter it's delicious speaking of
salad you started out as the salad girl
in the 70s and a high-end climb the
culinary ladder well I hated being a
salad girl I really wanted to cook and
at that time I was really about the only
woman in a major restaurant in Boston
and so I just decided I would go to
cooking school and come back and they
would take me a little more seriously
and I did I went to London I hocked my
diamond ring did you really yeah because
you were married and I was married and
then yes exactly and I had my first baby
at 17 but that marriage did not work out
so I hocked my
and I went to cooking school and you
know came back and I went right back to
Maison robear and they said okay you can
come on
you know we'll make you a cook well you
obviously I mean first of all you've
broken so many glass ceilings and you
obviously left your mark but I mean it's
lovely when your patrons your customers
are the ones who rave over you and you
had a very special person who would come
and sit and just adored your food well
she called me I was working at Maison
Robair and she called me one day and I
picked up the phone and she said why
don't you come to lunch tomorrow she had
you know at her house at her house yes
she did she made she was working on a
Roquefort jelousy tart for her new book
and Paul was sitting at the table and I
walked in she was so just fresh normal
just so sweet and and she asked me to
make the salad dressing for the salad to
go with this puff pastry tart and of
course you know my knees started shaking
and you know I went to the sink and I
started whisking oil in the salad and I
was you know was one of those moments
but you two became friends very good
friends in fact the last dinner she had
in Boston before she went to assisted
living in Santa Barbara she came to LA
Cober and had dinner with nine of her
best friends and it was very special for
me and but she invited me on the qe2
with her well she called me she said
Lydia I want to go to Harrods and eat
oysters and drinks since they're with
you so he invited me on that trip well
there's any one pastor present as you
sign this - oh thank you love to enjoy
this meal with who would that be
well I don't probably say Richard Olney
or James Beard Wow James Beard was a
great gossiper you know
[Laughter]
among other things we appreciate you
joining us bringing us thank you a
Beulah Smeal and for more on chef
Lydia Shire and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning
dot-com